so again congratulations is a very cool
movie very cool to see as a die-hard
Godzilla fan no thanks so much
my favorite part though the action is
very impressive is actually the
personality that you give to the
monsters and the way that you interact
with them I noticed in the credits that
there were three actors for Ghidorah who
can you talk briefly about that process
yeah I mean I I really wanted to embrace
the idea that each of Ghidorah heads
have their own distinct personality that
each head would react differently when
faced with a difficult situation like
fighting Godzilla and so and we were
gonna do mocap performance capture for
certain sequences so I said it would be
fun to hire three different actors to
play each head and so we did that we
would have one actor named TJ storm
portraying Godzilla and then three other
actors playing King Ghidorah and that
way when they faced off with each other
they could sort of play off of each
other and just just bring some unique
aspects to that relationship awesome I
think it really paid off for you on set
how much of a sense of the personality
were you able to get for the monsters
since a lot of that is effects and
things that come after you know he
cannot understand about the whole thing
Godzilla mm-hmm but he's he gave some
hope for for humankind or something and
then uh just as an aside test then you
know just I fight to the Gosselaar a
long time but I some kind of a trust
yeah and then it's really complicated
feeling that that sequence is you know
yeah it's a beautiful scene thank you so
I know that you are kind of a fellow
diehard of the Godzilla I'm curious not
yours and not the first one what would
be your three must-see Godzilla movies
ooh Ghidorah the three-headed monster
because that's the first time you see
this particular group of creatures come
together I was a huge fan of Final Wars
because it's just nuts I mean it's just
bonkers and then I know it doesn't count
as a it's a kaiju film and but it's bro
Dan solo film because that was the first
time I saw such a strong flying creature
what we're I mean obviously the the
films are these characters had the
origins but what was the the flavor of
previous films that you wanted to kind
of absorb here uh well something I loved
about sort of the long evolution of
Godzilla movies is that they got more
fantastical as they went along you know
the first film is just pure science
fiction
I felt very real very grounded and then
as they started to adding these new
creatures they started to feel like
science fantasy but they always retained
you know their very strong message and
allegory but they they got they weren't
afraid to go for it were you ever was
there ever a discussion where it was
like you can play with all these toys
but not these monsters because we want
to make a movie with them in the future
no honestly yeah it was um I had free
rein that pretty much do anything I mean
they definitely suggested Rodan Mothra
and King Ghidorah so it was just it was
an easy yes awesome well they are
wrapping me so soon it was lovely to
talk with you thank you thank you very
much